know I guess we might as well start um
our first uh
subcommittee um meeting of the morning
um this is uh House Bill 267 relative to
criminal record checks in School in
school
employment
um and this was um brought forward by
Joe Alexander representative Joe
Alexander um at the request of his
Goffstown
superintendent uh basically to um allow
for more uh periodic uh background
checks of employees within the uh School
District um and we did get uh an
amendment from Joe
Alexander um I did not bring a hard copy
um if if anyone has a hard copy or um
have it can you bring it up um
KY I just don't know how you want me to
send it to HCS or uh can you just read
just the
changes
so the changes begin on let me see this
well I'll just read
20 um the superintendent of the school
administrative unit or the chief
executive officer of the chartered
public
school or public Academy May
negotiate with the respective Union for
that school administration
administrative unit chartered public
school or the public Academy to allow
the superintendent to conduct criminal
history records checks on a reoccurring
basis after the initial criminal history
check is conducted for purposes of
employment any such criminal history
records check shall comply with the
procedures set forth in this
section I'm trying to remember where
begins
oh he had some definitions and some
language regarding which particular
schools would be right right this would
apply to yeah um because I think part of
our original discussion was that um
contract
negotiations um would have to be
involved um in the process um which was
not in the original uh bill um that was
brought forward um and I know that uh uh
attorney Fenton had worked on this um
Amendment um and she I got a message
from her she is on the way she's a few
minutes late um but this amendment does
address that um and I
checked um last week with the
superintendent baky from
gtown and he confirmed that through the
reason that he uh was interested in this
um legislation and had approached
representative Alexander was because he
did um try to go the union negotiation
route um but um received um there's
attorney
Fenton
um uh did not receive a favorable
response to entering negotiations to all
um the uh more frequent background
checks um and was cited that there was
nothing in statute um about more
frequent background checks so that was
the reason that he um put forward um
this
amendment um uh attorney Fenton would
you like to talk about the amendment um
that you had drafted um uh
representative Al alander sent it to us
um the other day and um it was just read
morning
on
um so attorney Fenton um while hard I
are being made um as I think I mentioned
uh representative Alexander did email
the amendment to us and um uh I was just
wondering if uh you would like to I
believe you uh drafted this for him um
if you'd like to comment on
it certainly good morning uh for the
record my name is Diana Fenton I'm an
attorney with the Department of
Education I apologize for running a few
minutes late I was in a meeting with
Frank so as I like to say uh it's
Frank's fault that I'm late um and if
he's watching this I apologize um so
good morning thank you for uh your time
at the last hearing I want to make clear
um it was brought to my attention that I
my testimony was interpreted as being
against the bill and I want to be clear
uh with this committee that as a state
employee I am not here to express an
opinion for or against a bill um that
I'm only here to provide technical
assistance I'm not a political appointee
um and so if my testimony was uh receive
that way I do apologize I was just here
to to provide information I was asked uh
by the sponsor and the superintendent
who um was interested in bringing this
bill forward if I could redraft it and I
I did I put some words together that I
thought addressed his concern
18913a it's earlier in the chapter and
it simply allows for the superintendent
to enter into that negotiation as I
testified last time it really has
nothing no impact on the Department of
Education um it's simply a matter of
employment has nothing to do with what
the department oversees but I know there
were a lot of questions last time I'm
happy to answer them the best to the
ability thank you for being here and
thank you for taking my question um in
Your
Capacity in working with the Department
how many incidents have you come across
problem thank you for the question and a
particular well how many how many times
if you had a superintendent contact you
with this with this
issue expressing a desire to do uh a
more frequent background check truly a
very small handful less than five I
would say and those are just all
anecdotal examples now thank you
uh if there is a
problem with it's just a followup if
there's a problem with an employee
employee you know they get arrested or
whatever the situ isn't it isn't there
current law that mandates a a
recognition or at least a report of that
incident so if someone is arrested for
one of the disqualifying offenses have
set out in statute um under the code of
conduct they have to report it to their
superintendent yes so if I had had a um
another followup excuse me uh so if I
had been been a senior employee and been
there for 20 years and uh I did
something that would violate the code
Etc uh it would mandate that that notice
would then have to be given correct it
doesn't get pushed under the rug or
anything like that so I'll just clarify
your example if I may yes if you were a
longterm employee at a school district
and you were arrested for one of the
disqualifying offenses you would be
required to report that to the
superintendent there could be additional
school
policy which would require you to report
any type of arrest I suppose that would
be possible but that would be a local
policy issue so what when the
superintendent was here before us
earlier this
session he was concerned about I think
particularly those senior
employees that uh were there prior to
his being hired as I recall and he was
just he was concerned about the ability
to have another background check is that
necessary if in fact the when you're
initially employed there is a background
check that's made correct that is
correct yes uh so um what would be the
incident rate I mean what would be the
reason for wanting to have another one
just because as a superintendent well
you know Mel's been here for SE several
years I want to check him out well let
me clarify my answer a little bit
under the law as it stands now RSA 18
18913a upon employment there is a
background check I cannot speak to what
the law was 20 years ago when someone
reason this is not a bill the department
has requested to be brought forward I
it's hard for me to testify as to the
why someone else wanted to bring this
bill forward I think my role here is
somewhat limited um I can answer some
technical questions I can testify as to
why I wrote what I wrote um but again
speaking on behalf of someone else I
think the intent the desire if you will
was simply to have the flexibility
perhaps to work that into a negotiation
but I'm not going to go any further in
my testimony than
this thank you as I read this language
would you say that this is permissive
language enabling
language give me one second to have my
exactly my thought when I wrote this was
to make
it a local control issue first and
foremost absolutely 100% falling within
the realm of employment nothing to do
with the Department of Education and to
make it permissible only not a mandate
in any sense of the word um the the
thought was to leave an enormous amount
of flexibility to the local districts to
enter into this negotiation with the
Union if they would like to do so as you
can see I think these are very uh broad
parameters the department did not craft
anything that gets into a lot of
detail that was the intent that was
expressed to me and that's what I tried
to capture here again keeping in mind I
play a unique role here this is not a
department issued bill this was just a
request
sure
understanding thank you um any further
yes thank
you I had a note from the initial
discussion about this bill that's not
regarding whether this only applies to
groups of employees or whether it could
individual yeah thank you for the
question that was certainly a concern
that I echoed at my prior
testimony and I think the the bill that
was previously before this
committee I think there was some
potential for that
um the way I crafted this my My Hope was
to make it as I previously testified to
an exclusive local control issue that
they could negotiate out so they could
address those
concerns I share your concern that this
allowance if you will could be used to
Target an individual I don't think
anyone has express that to me and I
would be remiss if we saw it used that
way so I wanted to craft it very broadly
to allow for those local negotiations to
occur so that at the local level they
could make sure that that didn't occur
they could make sure that it was broadly
individual I appreciate your explanation
of the intent of what was crafted makes
sense and I
still kind of wonder if it would be
better if it's specifically said
something along the lines of nothing in
this law shall be used to require an
individual to have a records check
distinct from the group calendar or
slots I would not be opposed to that I
certainly think that is well within this
committee's decision to add in that
additional language I think what I have
created is really a
framework and within that framework
could you add
those pieces that you feel would add
protection yes that's certainly within
the realm of this committee to do so
um I think the way that it is crafted I
trust the negotiations at the local
level to address those concerns but
certainly this legis it is well within
this legislative body's uh prerogative
those
representative Luna thank you very much
Mr chair and uh and and and thanks um
Diana for uh for being here but and also
for um for uh sending over the uh the
draft amendment in um in reading it um
is would would this sort of you know
secondary
um or more more frequent um check of
criminal
history only apply to um um employees or
units the appropriate application of
because it's to be negotiated at the
local level so it would in the only
apply to those individuals who are in
that negotiating unit yes okay so follow
up on that so so it it wouldn't apply to
let's say um uh an office manager in a
public school who may not be a member of
the um the teachers or support staff
Union some are some aren't and it
wouldn't apply to the director of
student services who operates under a um
um a a a directly I mean that you know
the director of student services
typically will have a an employee
contract but that would be a one-on-one
negotiator with the superintendent in
board
okay I whole idea was to allow that
local level negotiation to occur and to
have those individuals who would be
subject to this additional background
check have a voice in that with your
union but and just just a final question
on on this string um and and so it would
it would not permit the um the the
superintendent or head of school to to
make um more frequent background checks
a condition of employment other
than as a condition of employment for a
an employee who is a member of a
collective bargaining unit or has a
contract as a result of that collective
bargaining
unit
I think as I'm puzzling this out a
little bit if we look at the reason
super
don't
reason feel that they don't have the
ability to run a background
check after that initi and so this is
that permissive language that they are
required to have the department of
safety cannot disseminate the federal
background check without statutory
enabling
ised don't think it would be broader
than that um because again you have a
few layers of protection this talks
about the respective Union for that uh
particular district and then the
department of safety can't disseminate
the
record without this enabling language
which again I think is narrowly tailored
to just that group of people who are
represented so so the re reason I'm
bringing this up Mr chair and and and
and Miss Hunton is because like for
example the um the the the
school that serves the largest number of
public school students in the state
by far M um I don't believe has
collective bargaining so this wouldn't
even apply in in the situation of a
school that
employs and you know and I'm you know by
virtue of the number of students that
they serve probably more teachers than
any other school in New
Hampshire so I guess I'm you know I'm
sorry I was a few minutes late but I'm
wondering if this is such a big problem
I would think it would certainly be a
at a larger school as opposed to a
smaller school and this wouldn't even
apply to the largest school in the
state and with all due respect I'm not
sure if there's a question there but I
understand where you're coming
from this is very narrowly
would
langu um and I again want to be clear in
my testimony this is not a department
sponsored bill this is not a request the
department
um and the department has no opinion as
to PR on this bill but this
committee this committee had a lot of
questions I was happy to try to bring
something before this committee that
might be palatable it is certainly
within this committee's discretion to to
um the superintendent Association is not
here to talk about this bill I don't
know how far-reaching this is I know
what I was asked to do and I brought it
forward to to see if this could gain
some traction to see if it could address
some of the
concerns um and I think your point is
well taken it's it's not supposed to be
broad-based it's supposed to be very
narrowly tailored as was requested just
that ability that was what was expressed
to me give the superintendent the
ability to enter into that negotiation
with the Union I think that's what this
bill addresses or at least that was
certainly my intent does it address all
the corresponding issues that could come
from that I don't think it does that's
do um if I any other questions of
attorney Fenton um if I could just I do
have one
okay good morning good morning um you
you you spoke just very briefly just now
that this appears to be a singular issue
coming from
gtown you don't know where the other
super the superintendent Association is
on this um so that's my first concern is
it wise for us to build legislation
around a singular District or should we
doing something that's applicable
Statewide and secondly I have the
question are there any employees within
school districts that you know of
whether they're certificated or not that
require more than one criminal
background check other than the initial
For Hire what about school bus drivers
um well can you just ask that do you
know if any other employees that require
yeah um no off the top of my head I mean
the way the statute is written for
purposes of
employment a criminal background check
is done on at the time of employment and
that's for contractors that's for
certified
educators
custodians School Personnel across the
board uh even volunteers they're subject
designated volunteers are subject to the
same level of background check um with
newer Educators they are now getting a
background check upon licensing because
the department does not want to license
someone who might be
unemployable and then they go into
employment and that background check at
the employment level can be more
thorough it goes beyond the
disqualifying offense
um and so to answer your question in
that way yes now there is that
two-tiered approach of background checks
but for employment purposes I can't
think of a group of individuals who are
subject to more than one background
check upon employment thank
you um with as as you just said with the
employment background check um it's more
comprehensive so you get to see
misdemeanors corre um Etc um and what
we're talking about here would be an
employment check rather than a a
licensing background check criminal
record check so so if that initial
employment uh check is done only at the
uh initial certification additional
licensing um there could be U
misdemeanors um that uh um a person
would be convicted of um over the years
that um a uh superintendent or a
district might consider um
questionable um based on uh that
person's status and the nature of the
misdemeanor um over the years um and
those things would not be caught
necessarily at this point is is that
correct that is it seems to be going off
periodically uh
that is correct and if I may
explain the background check that is
done currently by the Department of
Education is only for those
disqualifying offenses anything that
would make someone unemployable by
Statute the Department's policy
is the department does not want to
license an individual who is statutorily
unemployable in our schools that being
said when we pivot away from lure and we
look at employment
representative cordelli is correct
school districts by Statute are allowed
to be much broader in their discretion
they are still subject to the
disqualifying offenses as is the
department but they can create a policy
that allows them to account for anything
that is found in that criminal
record the other important piece for
this legislature uh legislative
committee to consider is to recognize
that
18913a has been changed dramatically
over the past eight or nine
years and 10 years ago school districts
were not receiving criminal records 10
years ago school districts were not
subject to this information 10 years ago
and I'm using that number broadly but
it's a good
Milestone 10 years ago it was the
department of safety that would read
through an applicant's criminal record
and they would then send a letter to the
school district and say and it was a
binary option yes you can hire no you
cannot and so as this legislative
committee considers this uh bill before
it I think it's important to keep in
mind that the nature of criminal history
checks has changed dramatically so
people who were employed 20 years ago
were subject to a very different
analysis than individuals who are hired
today or even three years ago this
legislative body has made dramatic
changes in this area of the
law if I could follow up so for an
employe for an employee um who was hired
10 15 even 20 years ago um the statute
has changed in terms of offenses and
disqualifying offenses Etc which
probably or possibly could not have been
caught back on the initial uh criminal
record check um but this would allow
through a negotiation process to do a
new background
check um and possibly look at what is
now a disqualifying offense would that
be the case yes and one more followup um
I think you you just brought it up a
minute ago in that
um in this District um if the union had
agreed to negotiate more frequent
background checks um that would have um
been one step forward but because there
was no language in
statute they could not get the FBI data
from the Department of Public Safety is
that also correct that is correct the
department of safety cannot disseminate
the federal background check to a school
district or to the Department of
Education for that matter without
enabling statutory language simply put
it has to be in the book it has to be
allowed for for do Department of Safety
to then disseminate that record to a to
a governmental entity I.E a school
district or state agency so the real
purpose of
this enabling or um uh permissible uh
language is to allow for the district to
get that FBI
language to receive the record yes yes
yeah represent Miler uh what's the
what's the feed for running
record check now oh gosh
um I'm going to Ballpark it and it
really is a ballpark
$50 and I think there is language in the
statute currently that says the school
district uh may require the individual
to pay that or the school district uh
picks up that cost and each district
determination yes repr thanks very much
and and follow on to to that if um uh if
an
employee actually let me let me back it
up further than that if an individual
wanted to contact the department of
safety and get of an FBI background
criminal history check on themselves
could they pay $50 and do that and then
get the report directly from the you
safety
you the answer is I don't know there's
been mixed information on that the FBI
department um my understanding is that
there are regulations by the FBI that
would prited I use myself as an example
from contacting the FBI and hey I want
to take a look at my own record here's
money I could beong
don't
understand the reason it came up and the
reason I struggled with is if you
take if you take a private contractor
for
example Diana's janitorial
services that is a non governmental
entity they're not subject they cannot
receive the FBI background check they
can get the New Hampshire background
check I can go on to the New Hampshire
portal and type in my name or type in my
neighbor's name and receive their New
Hampshire criminal record but that is
limited to the state of New
Hampshire and so when we saw all these
various changes occurring in
18913a part of the driving Factor
representative luno was the recognition
that a private company I.E Diana's
janitorial services can't receive the
full background check they can't get the
federal background check but the
Department of Education can because it
is a governmental entity
SAU one can because it is a governmental
entity we saw this with Brewster
Academy and all nonpublic sorry to pick
on Brewster Academy but Brewster Academy
is not a governmental entity and it
check we worked with the feds to get
them an exception under the Adam wal
Shack because it is a child safety issue
so
that's how I have become aware of some
of those regulations which would
prohibit individuals from just calling
up and and receiving it because if that
was the solution we could say to all the
individual contractors just call the FBI
directly and request it it is an issue
of
dissemination and that's what the FBI is
concerned about and again I'm not here
to speak on behalf of the FBI that's my
understanding just a just a quick follow
up on on that well it may not be quick
um but
thanks for the war so so well the
followup but the answer may be the the
um so this exception
for non-government entities that you
were just talking about what does that
apply to the exception is just under the
Adam Walsh act and that was just
for those non-public
schools to have access to the federal
background check but that's not
necessarily applicable
to but but the they would have access to
the federal background check through the
Department of Education because they can
only I thought you said they can only
disseminate to a government they can
only disseminate to a governmental
entity or another entity that is allowed
under the adom wall sha okay all right
and a good example of the Adam Walsh act
putting aside the non-public schools um
like a camp any program that works
exclusively with children my
understanding my limited understanding
of the Adam Walsh Act is it is that
child safety exception and and and the I
knew there was a reason I was was asking
this can they do that on an annual or
fre or more frequent basis or only on
the only as a condition prior to hiring
the
employee my understanding is the way the
law is written it is upon employment
only I do not believe it would be
allowed for a reoccurring basis okay but
again I'm getting pushed out of my
comfort zone a little bit so I'm going
to put an asterisk next to that
testimony um because I'm I don't work
for the FBI I don't know all their regs
it is really a cursory understanding and
I don't want to mislead you in anyway
fair enough that is my understanding
thanks very much represent
L maybe I can push you back into your
comfort zone here that would be great on
lines 20 and 21 you speak about the
superintendent of the school
administrative unit or the chief
executive officer but in lines 20 on
line 23 you only speak of the
superintendent um is there a is that a
uh the second line should it read or
like you have up top where there may not
be a superintendent in a charter school
yes that's simply a typo where you left
out the four four words five words okay
secondly um If This Were to
pass uh Are We Now setting up a
situation
where you have some districts that are
not able to do this there is no Union
and those that are which have a union is
Peter going to start coming after Paul
and say Hey you can do it so why can't I
do it as a superintendent or chief
administrative officer um should we if
we're doing something like this should
we make it then uh more Statewide to
involve all districts but we're only
involving those districts are union
districts that's the
question and there's two question you
one
if it is this legislature legislative
body's intent to have it applicable to
all districts then this language that is
suffice it's really a policy
determination to say if it's going to be
applicable to all or to defer to local
control and uh that would be beyond the
scope of my
testimony okay I'll follow that up if I
may then so the intent or the rational
behind this is for a superintendent to
address an issue which he feels or she
feels that's necessary wouldn't that
same situation might that same situation
occur in some other District that didn't
have a
union the answer to both your questions
is yes
you any further questions for attorney
Fenton represent Miler well Rick raises
an interesting issue for me and and that
is if there's an
occurred that would need a record check
or something isn't there some other form
of discipline or prog or Progressive
nature of
discipline that would address this or
even fall under the uh code of conduct
that would trigger this kind of a thing
I mean I just I'm just concerned about
this law of enacting a piece of
legislation kind of what Rick was saying
earlier where you have one
superintendent who's come forward i' I
got a problem here and then all of a
sudden everything so my question is
excuse me the question is is there if
there is an incident that would cause
some
concern isn't there aren't there other
factors that a superintendent could
follow rather than having the necessar
this
I'm going to push back on your question
just slightly simply because you're
making it targeted at an
individual and that's not what this
legislation was designed to do this
legislation if used in accordance with
his intent would be more
broad-based and shouldn't be used
to address as you say a a problem with
an
individual that was certainly not my
thought when when I spoke to the
superintendent that's not what was
conveyed to me and that's not the
purpose behind this as far as I
understood it to be so I push back only
because I think you're talking about a
particular fact pattern and an
individual whereas this is not intended
to be applied that way I hope that helps
thank you I like to follow sure and I'll
follow up on represent where we were
just now uh dealing with the issue of
broad base but this legislation is
allowing the local school district to
decide this employment issue uh whether
it's targeted towards an individual or a
broad base it's going to be determined
by that negotiation so when we say that
uh but this is not necessarily broad
base um we don't
know you're you're right I I would
certainly hope that you know what was
expressed to me was not a desire to say
well there's a problem I need to conduct
another background check on on Diana
Fenton problem employee the the thought
was I want to as a superintendent be
able to negotiate this possibility with
the Union not to say well now I need it
as a tool and now I want to administer
this and so it was to put it as part of
contract negotiations along with a whole
host of other
superintendent utilize it in those
contract negotiations I suppose they
could
but and I will defer to the union to
testify to this but my understanding is
when you have those contract
negotiations they are more broad-based
more broad arching it's not about an
individual and and again that's just my
understanding of it so I would be
surprised if this was to be used
to address a grievance with one
particular individual that's not what
was expressed to me when I spoke with
the superintendent and again limited
knowledge base but that's that is the
spirit in which I drafted this amendment
and it is certainly within the purview
of this committee to make mod I'm
somewhat concerned about where we're
going with this um if I'm the the
teacher on a playground a given an
analogy here and there's a individual
screwing up on the
yard do I line the whole playground kids
up on the wall or the one kid that's
screwing up on the
wall um it seems to me whether if if
this if the effort behind all this is to
deal with an individual this is the
wrong way to do it we're passing some
legislation that's a blanket for groups
what have you
rather than dealing with the specific
issue so I I I'm a little bit perplexed
as to where we're going with this in
terms of what is the initial intent and
the purpose of this what is the end of
this what's that Endzone look like where
are we going and
why my understanding of the spirit of
this proposal was that it was supposed
to be proactive in nature not reactive
I think the state government is Infamous
for being reactive and not proactive and
the thought from the superintendent and
again it's difficult to testify on
someone else's behalf
but the thought that as a superintendent
I want the ability to negotiate this and
it might not come to fruition I might
not be successful in those
negotiations that's part of the nature
of negotiations and that's fair game but
I want to have it as a bargaining chip
because I want to be able to subject
School Employees who are covered by the
union so that I make sure that they are
in fact
safe for lack of a better term and again
I'm stepping outside of my role here but
I can imagine from a superintendent's
position give me the tools to ensure
that these children are
safe give me that tool or at least give
me the opportunity to negotiate for it
and I think that is what is being asked
but again I put a big asteris by that
testimony because I'm not a superintend
attendant I'm not a
lobbyist I was asked to draft this I
drafted it and here we are having a
great time talking about it but
um I think that's really the decision
this legislative committee has to has to
consider I think it is being asked as a
tool I don't think it's being used to
Target anyone individual and I would be
very remiss if it was used in that way
can I have one last thank you so
is your impression that this is you talk
about
proactive is this really proactive if it
were proactive what it not come from the
superintendent Association School boards
Association and the various associations
are representing Educators out in the
field but this is not this is coming
individual I think that is a very fair
concern to to bring up again I can't
speak for those other groups I I don't
know who has vetted this legislation in
terms of those other organizations and
they're certainly free to uh attend
these hearings and and speak as to their
position on this bill I'm not in a
position to say
that further questions for attorney
Fenton you seen none thank you very much
that's it yeah well we've got more bills
so so stick
around thank you very much um any other
conversation with the subcommittee
um I I think um yes yeah I just have a a
comment um chairman lad um I think our
duty as legislators is to listen to
constituents and not just Union
representation and we had a constituent
who also happens to be a superintendent
bring this legislation forward um so I
didn't necessarily think he was being
reactive I thought he was being
proactive in trying to prevent future
situations like this from occurring
sure our responsibility here as an
education committee we represent
education in the state of New Hampshire
not necessarily in one specific district
and it's important that when we enact we
enact legislation it's appropo or
applicable to all districts and have
intent and rationale behind why we're
doing it uh I'm not negating what's
going on particularly in gtown but there
there's a process which we have to
follow but also that the superintendent
should be following and working
collectively together they bring forward
and Su of the so does the school boards
Association recommended policies which
they're working towards in any given
year they share that with us and then we
go forward if we react to every singular
issue that comes our statutes are going
to be much much larger than what we
necessarily see you know we see the
green book that representative Tanner
was wanting to see every year we're
going to have to be carrying around you
know a cart pulling all this stuff so I
I I'm concerned that we we en enact
legislation that is really necessary and
rather than creating something here
which this is going to lead to another
piece of legislation because it's going
to be applicable only to certain
districts so it's lining up for more
legislation in fact let's do it right
when we initially do it thank
you I followup followup yes I I do agree
with that I don't necessarily think that
this is the particular vehicle with
which to but I think it did open up um
an area which does need some attention
paid to it and so I would thank that
superintendent for bringing this forward
because it did bring this discussion to
our attention I can respond to that too
as an administrator I've been in
situations like this however um I I it
this this issue is
a broad issue targeted or for whole
groups uh one District vers another
District whether you have a union or not
there are just too many Loose Ends Here
uh there is uh something behind it yes
that's maybe we need to be looking at
and and working collectively with uh a
broader range of folks to get something
done that's going to be more lasting in
nature veror
Damon thank
you I think I have three
thoughts one is it keeps sticking in my
head attorney Fenton's observation that
this statute has changed a lot since 10
years
ago
and it has raised my
concern that in fact we might not know
the background of people who are
hired long enough ago that the current
criminal records checks didn't apply to
them so that I think is something
to perhaps as chair lad said consider in
What legislation might look like I mean
I think we could amend this bill to
include the broader array that has been
referred to not just the public
schools and I've now forgotten my third
piece oops I'll stop there until it
comes back thank you um thank you I I
uh I think that um before November 13th
it is our full committee meeting um you
know as you've got your third point I
did go ahead it seems that we could ask
the professional associations that we
don't know what they think we could ask
them to tell us what they
think thank you um I think there can be
um between now and the 13th additional
looking at this language and possibly
other language to address some of the
concerns but um uh I also think that it
has um raised an issue um representative
Damon you just mentioned one in terms of
the length of time after that initial
employment check um and the fact that um
without statutory language if and if a
district did negotiate uh further
background checks um they could not get
the full set of information because it's
not in in statute um so I think that's
uh for me that's an important point also
and um you know I um you know we'll try
and find some time to uh you know play
around with the language a little bit
myself and hopefully uh others might
worthwhile anything well I I just think
that there there's none of our
associations and none of those non uh
folks which are not in Associates that
don't don't all want safety in our
schools and and and they have uh you
know folks in their schools which are
appropriate to be around children I
think we all agree on that uh so I think
this is something we shouldn't let go
but uh it you're right representative
cordelli it does you know maybe
something can be crafted uh however if
we do so I think we have to do it with
support of of all people that are coming
in contact with these
children okay thank you um I guess with
that we'll we'll close
on this bill uh 267 for today and um
we'll be revisiting it um and we have
another uh Bill uh to address during
this set of um bills um and that is
House Bill
628 which requires certain non Public
Schools or educational service providers
that accept public funds to perform
background checks on all employees and
volunteers um and um I think
representative Miler you had something
you wanted to pass out and and uh I do
as
well
me
sure we can take take a few minutes to
uh
yes so we'll we'll take a few minutes
breaks anyway in between um five minutes
and uh we can look over this
material okay
sure uh do you want to
start
unforunately is down uh with a very
difficult cold at this point in time so
she was she's unable to be here her uh
the intent of her amendment to her bill
is to eliminate uh any uh thought that
the homeschooled parents would not have
to go through a background check that's
basically what she was trying to do with
you
and what BR pass out information from
several
organizations in terms of their
background check policy um one is from
um
prena um there is another from uh David
tibo who is the um chair of the
non-public schools advisory Council and
the third is um uh
from um a previous bill but on the same
topic um from the
diis of
Manchester um in regards to their
policies um so we can take a few minutes
there
just
right this is yeah this is the second 9
o' this
okay
are we okay to um everyone had enough
time to read through these materials
minutes
that's
you
the
everybody good to
go great um shall we um represent Miler
first
right
that um homeschool parents would not be
involved in
this but that but that others who are
receiving uh public funds would be uh
would be covered under this her her
yeah
because that was a major concern I think
when we talked about before she heard
that and wanted to make sure that it was
clear that uh this would she thinks this
would deal with
that uh yes so I just want to make sure
I'm in section 3D where it says the
section shall not ptain to a parent
giving a Nona home education program to
their children so basically what this is
making clear is a parent is not going to
be having to get a criminal background
check to educate their own children but
what about these situations in which
parents informally come together so
which I am becoming more and more
familiar with and where a neighbor uh
is maybe is better with math and so they
get to together in a sort of a informal
pod I don't know if that's the correct
word would those parents be required
to have a background check what I'm
becoming more and more familiar with is
this idea that you know I used to think
homeschooling was a parent just teaching
their kids and what I've learned is that
it's a lot different than that so so
just some I don't know if you can give
it because it's not your Amendment but I
don't want that's what I I take issue
with most with this this law this bill
is the burden it puts on
um parents who other parents know well
they have a relationship with they trust
and they will be subject to criminal
background checks
so I don't know if this
language doesn't address that it just
says a parent doesn't have
to with their own children doesn't need
a background check which don't answer I
mean obviously that that should be the
case just want to bring that up and if
anyone can offer clarification represent
Miler or yeah I can I can take it um and
and I think in sections one and sections
two which um which address the
conditions that would uh would um
require a uh uh criminal history records
check would not apply in the cases you
just mentioned because it doesn't um
it doesn't talk about home schooling it
talks about specific specific programs
to learn everywhere program the
program or are other funded program
through through a scholarship
organization so that would be like the
um so so I I think in the situation
where you've got um you know a neighbor
who's coming over to to teach a
homeschooled child music or art or
something like that it neither in
section one or section two does it
person um if I could mention on that
same section uh section
3D um the last
this section shall not pertain to a
parent giving a non-fa home education
program to their children but we do have
e we do have homeschooled parents with
EFA
accounts so they would be subject to the
background check but but those aren't
homeschool kids those are EFA kids we've
we've we we've heard that from the
commissioner that those aren't
considered homeschool um those are
considered EFA students
students but I I don't think that's
clear in this in this section I the way
I read it is that if a parent is giving
a non-fa home education program to the
children there they don't have to submit
the records check but a parent who is
giving an um a program to a CH their
children with an EFA account they do
have to qualify or submit the background
check
repres there are there are four ways
that in our state of New Hampshire that
compulsory attendance can be uh
accomplished one
homeschooling EFA public and private
those the four links there is a a
difference between EFA and homeschooling
they are separate programs if you
receive an EFA you're part and recorded
as an EFA student so I think that should
clarify that but I I have a problem on
line
19 where it's talking about the
children's scholarship organization
funded programs are you talking is this
talking about the education tax credit
if so those are not government monies
those are monies which are tax credit
monies from business and they don't go
to the state we've had this discussion
over and over and over and so I don't
want to see any
linkage uh for this program applying to
uh students which are receiving solely
credit so so let me let me um would it
be acceptable to you if
we took out um from the end of line 19
or our children scholarship funded
programs take out that
part and and basically just leave learn
everywhere and um um EFA program I I
think representative luno that that is a
concern and that needs to be struck from
this bill should it move forward my
overarching concern here is
that we have a number of private excuse
me number of private schools in the
state which we have students that are
tuition
to and they could be anything from uh a
a holderness Kimble Union to you know
those are private
schools and but they could receive
tuition students based upon the way we
have the tuition program set
up uh I'm concerned that we got to be
very careful in over regulating private
schools if we do so we're going to lose
that opportunity for them to receive
tuition students they're going to say
you know it's not worth one or two or
three students but every student's
important so uh I'm real concerned that
we not encroach into private schools
that are separate from public they're
functioning basically yes they do
receive some tuition programs but
that's I I think we got to be very
careful if I could just mention in
regard to that that um the handouts um
that I provided um one of which is from
uh prena with their background um check
policy um which includes an annual
background check for their um
instructors um and also from the uh
chair of the non-public school um
advisory
Council um who really Echoes the same
thing that the previous uh chair echoed
back in
1999 um to uh excuse me 2019 to Prior
legislation um that if you're accredited
by Nas you have to perform background
checks and every school in New Hampshire
approved for attendance by the state
part of their P part of the process to
get approved is that you are going to be
performing background checks
um so I I think that it um I'll also
mention I was pointed out in one of
these that um these
policies go further than the public
school policy and the public school
policies um just require background
checks for designated volunteers where
these um do not have that restriction
and volunteers generally um are required
to have background
checks
yeah re luno thank thanks very much I
mean as we as we heard um public school
policies require um criminal history
background checks the national uh
Crystal um FBI criminal history
background check for any prospective um
uh new hire so so I I would I would not
say that that the example given here in
prena goes beyond what our what our
public schools um is doing are doing and
and I think even even more
concerning to
me uh you know in reading the U the
prena background check policy is it
seems
to conflict with
um what we just heard on the last bill
and and um and I was wondering maybe if
um if if attorney Fenton might be able
to come up and and um particularly
address some of the um some of the
points that that prena is um
is you know talking about here and uh
whether or not that um that you know is
is actually even possible um uh to
happen because we know prena operates
here in the state of New Hampshire we
know they have employees who are called
guides we know they have
volunteers and we have them saying that
they do a federal criminal search in a
national criminal search um uh yet they
um yet we we've heard that the uh
superintendent in gtown can't uh can't
get that information so I so I'm not
quite sure why Kenda can get that
information
um working with public school kids and
non public school kids and a
superintendent can't get that
information it appears to be in
Conflict would you like to uh offer
Fenton so the qu the question would the
question would be um
uh would would prena through a um a
third-party um private company and they
they call it
Checker um be able to conduct the the uh
Crim the N the the Federal Criminal
search they call it here and a national
um would they be able to con to to
conduct those and um
and uh uh do those searches are those
searches equivalent to um to what uh
what the state of New Hampshire requires
for um for um uh for public schools
prior to hiring an
employee
today thank you for the question for the
record my name is Diana fent with the
Education
it would be the department of safety who
could best answer this question so with
that caveat in place my again my
understanding of the
system is the federal background check
does not get disseminated to
non-governmental
entities you referenced a thirdparty
background check company those are very
common again my my limited understanding
is this third-party private vendors cuz
that's what that is it's a part it's a
private vendor um does not have access
to the FBI background check they will do
computer searches they'll check public
records things of that nature um there
could be an exception through the atom
wall Shack uh by
which they are getting that information
that federal background check but I
don't know that for sure um again this
is my cursory understanding of that
checks if I could just point out the uh
letter from shaa nson um who works for a
pra nationally um that they comply with
18913a uh five that uh which I think are
the um disqualifying offenses right yes
can I ask uh sure a question um di if if
I'm a school district and I contract
with an agency let's say to provide the
services that we're looking for whether
it be speech or some other
area does the
agency is that the organization which
does the criminal background check um or
how's how's this this occurred the the
individual that comes out to do this may
not necessarily be a speech pathologist
it may be somebody doing the job under
the supervision of somebody within that
agency uh how do we know that that
individual coming to have oneon-one with
a
student um has criminal background
check my understanding is it is a
function of the school district it will
be the school district that will take on
that role and run that background check
and review it so if a school district's
Contracting with the agency to provide
that and Mrs Jones shows up today and
maybe Mr Smith the next day they have no
idea who is
coming so how do we ensure that there's
criminal background
checks is it the agency that's given
that check as an
individual so again and representative
cascaden might have personal experience
with this um given her prior role as a
superintendent I will change your fact
pattern briefly and if you take it more
broad-based custodial
Services those background checks are
performed by the school
district employing those those
individuals if you look at it as more
those one-on-one Services um it has been
problematic for the school district to
be able to conduct those background
checks because as you said it might be a
shif changing nature um those are very
fact dependent situations and they are
handled on a case-by Case basis by the
school district I have spoken to
superintendents who have grappled with
that from time to time um figuring out
how best to ensure the safety and comply
with the the law but in large part my
understanding is those private
entities do not have that access and the
school district
does thank
you repr Luna thank you very much Mr
chair um going back to uh to prena
what's the what's the what's the
Department's position on
um uh public schools using um using uh
prena pods to um to to in in
I guess inperson for inperson
instruction with a with a public school
student um I guess it's two parts of the
question what's the uh what's the
Department's position in in public
schools uh Contracting with prenda to
provide iners instruction and then
number two what is the Department's
position with respect to criminal
history records checks on pra employees
and volunteers that provide um in-person
C I don't know if I'm able to speak on
our position
um I can answer technical questions I
don't know if I'm here to speak as to
broad-based policy initiatives um well
so so so so let me I'll turn it into a
technical question then as opposed to a
policy initiative if um if the um if the
hoptman school district was to contract
with uh with
uh for a prena pod uh that used both
employee guides and volunteers to
provide in-person
instruction um what would the Hopkinson
school board's
responsibility be in so far as um as a
criminal history check on these um on
Personnel I I would have to look at that
contract I really don't I don't know the
interplay I do know that for all the
initiatives the department undertakes we
do so keeping in mind that criminal
history check is Paramount but I can
look into that interplay and get back to
I I just don't have okay thanks and that
that I think would be a big help and I
think you know the the question we're
putting putting for that just you know
put out here I think it's very similar
to what what Rick just put out with
respect to um you know a contracted
occupational therapist
service and um that that a school a
school May contract with you're not
quite sure who you're going to get for
personnel on any given day but what's
the school districts what's the school
board's responsibility as far as
criminal history check on these um uh on
these Personnel who are um uh providing
students represent Damon thank you um I
have three things to again maybe I'll
remember all three so just to clarify
representative cordelli on your remark
before we brought attorney Fenton
forward the amendment proposed to the
bill does specify designated volunteer
the original Bill didn't say designated
but the amendment does
statute y
y sorry so so it it is specific to
designated volunteer not um in the
amendment um my question to to attorney
Fenton my screen just close I'm on
Checker's website the company that the
prena um materials indicate they use and
in part it references doing their
Federal criminal records check through
Pacer which I'm not familiar with the
public access to court electronic
records can you comment
on what's available through that similar
to the questions that have been asked
about you know discussion of the prior
Bill information not being just readily
available to individuals Is this
that so I
just typed in Pacer as well I'm never
I've never explored this website uh
you've given me something to do this
afternoon um so I thank you very much um
um my understanding is you court is an
open
Forum anyone can walk into any
courthouse and listen to the
docket um and these are public documents
people don't think of them as public
documents but if you go into court you
can watch a trial you can hear a case
and you can hear what the verdict is you
can find out if someone's guilty this is
why we watch WMUR in the morning and
eagerly await where Ray Brewer is in the
morning before a courthouse they it is
public information it is a public record
I think what these private companies
such as Pacer do and again I I have
limited information but this is my
understanding is they can look up Diana
Fenton and individually say in the state
of New Hampshire has she been been
convicted of something in Nevada has she
been convicted of something and they go
through and it's just a constant
computer search
whereas pivot you can get all that
information or pivot and you go to the
federal background check and it's all
given to you on one paper right and so
the information is all
obtainable it's just how do you obtain
it it's not that it's private it's not
confidential it's just there's one
entity that compil it as part of their
administrative
obligation and then they can disseminate
it or I sit here and I type in Hope
Damon in all these different capacities
and I pull and compile the same
information I think that's what you're
finding that's what the third party
vendor
does so if I'm understanding you
correctly in theory Checker or other
companies like them through Pacer could
come up with all the information that
would be in the FBI record but they
would need to be very diligent and
thorough
to to do that I agree with that
statement yes thank you represent Pell
I'm sorry you sorry the last piece I had
is I just wanted to make the observation
that regardless of whether we agree or
disagree with the adequacy of the prena
process prena is by no means the only
micropod correct terminology if possible
uh option that is available in New
Hampshire so when we look at what we
might do with this
bill even if we think what pra is doing
is fine and adequate it doesn't cover
that
whole
students p know if we really want to
open up a can of worms in both of these
pieces of legislation if you look
further down the page on Checker they
have um continuous criminal background
checks so you can be alerted anytime
there's a reportable offense from your
active
Workforce um thank you um this should
wait yeah did you okay any further
questions for attorney Fenton seen none
much great have fun save you some work
this afternoon do it now um yes
representative it just seems to me that
in order for these
schools to remain in business they have
to provide a level of criminal
background checks that will maintain the
parents trust case in point well what
representative pel just mentioned about
that organization but just to draw your
attention to the dasis of
Manchester uh Robert Dunn and the final
paragraph of that letter
says that uh the dasis of Manchester has
a robust criminal background check
process in place for its School
Employees and volunteers he goes into
the details and then says the dasis of
Manchester has instituted these
procedures even even without the Mandate
that HB 1664 would impose um we don't
need this law these schools have to do
this in order to stay in business the C
and I know from personal experience the
Catholic schools went through a rough
time uh enrollment plummeted in order to
regain the trust of parents they had to
Institute impeccable standards of
background checks and they have regained
that trust greatly you know you know I I
I I just got to stop you right there the
Catholic schools went through a tough
time how about their students that were
abused they go through a tough time
say that this is oh the poor Catholic
schools I mean this
is this comment right here is just
laughable it happens in public schools
too so let's not go there what do you
mean it's laughable I kind of object to
this I'm just trying step back I'm
speaking from my own experience having
had a lot of experience with Catholic
schools as a parent having to go through
all the hoops and all the watching
videos and the fingerprints and the
background checks
what I my point is I'm just using it as
an example as PR do in order for these
private schools to maintain their
enrollment to have parents trust they
have to do this they that just for that
reason and and so do and they do it so
they do this without a mandate of a
government over overreaching with with
more
regulations um representative
p i I have to agree with representative
quell because I went through this also
and the silver lining in that in this in
that Scandal that the Catholic Church
went through had repercussions making
everybody aware of sexual abuse that can
occur any abuse that can occur and I
routinely go through training even
though I'm not a teacher to stay safe
having interactions with youth and I've
gone through multiple trainings as as a
a coach as a strok and turn judge for
swim teams as a soccer parent um and
I've seen people regardless of
background checks regardless of training
still behave as if the rules don't apply
to them and if if anything the other
letter that we received from Mr tibol
from the dicese emphasizes parents being
educated and I think that would be the
most important takeaway from any of this
legislation is that parents seek the
education they need to look for these
behaviors that they should be alerted to
so that they can keep their children
safe because regardless of the
background checks regardless of as much
safety we put
Educators volunteers anybody through
there are still criminals who will
behave in ways that supersede the
rules and as we've seen a background
check is a snapshot in time you know you
can have background check today but what
happens on Friday you know is something
different um I thought I saw someone
else with a hand up um yes
representative
Damon thank
you
so I don't understand and I would like
to
understand if in
fact the Catholic schools and various
other entities that are being
referenced are already so completely
thorough in their background checks then
why would there be an objection to what
this bill says because they would
already be doing
it repres P that's a very good question
because we just heard a bill where the
public schools have objection to further
background checks I'm seeing evidence
and I you you said um prle wasn't the
only example but I did see that acting
Academy in order to maintain your status
as an acting academy you need to perform
background checks every four years on
your Educators in that in that system we
have two AC andies in New Hampshire um
I'm my question and kind of a rebuttal
to your
statement is there any specific
situation or an example of a situation
that makes this legislation necessary
the the last bill that we heard there
was a specific situation that was
brought forward this one I'm not seeing
a specific situation I'm not seeing a
specific um organization that is having
concerns other than legislators who seem
to think it's necessary to attack um
recipients of Education Freedom accounts
or non um Public Schools um and quite
honestly has a former homeschooler I see
this as an attack by uh the public Ed
education system um on families that
they want more information from than
receiving I would hope that we could
find a
way to so prioritize the safety of all
children regardless of the environment
in which they receive
education that no one would perceive
this as an attack
and I come at this as a
victim so it deeply deeply troubles me
that we would put barriers in the path
of doing the best that we
can to assure that people who are
interacting with our children have no
criminal record history and yes
something could happen tomorrow that's
absolutely true in any
context
the majority of perpetrators of harm to
children are known to their
families
wonderful responsible well-intended
parents don't well-informed parents
don't always see it this is just a piece
I think both of these bills actually to
try to increase the level of safety will
never be perfect but it's not an attack
at least that's not at all how I
um I I would just say I think that
um I see it more of of an attack on
myself um and I don't think that as
we've seen with the documents um about
background check policies from various
organizations um they are I think
representative perinel you mentioned
that they're doing it without a
government mandate um they're doing it
because of their con concern um for
safety um and uh I I think it also leads
back to to the last bill and um doing
something so that uh background checks
are not performed um once um in a a
teachers uh or Educator's career um and
that's it
um so
are yes you had to thank you so
if the bill currently before
us is an attack which
I for me it totally is not but if it
is then the prior bill is also an attack
to a different population I mean I don't
think we can have it both ways we can
either say both bills Endeavor to create
a better safety net for
children or we can say they're both
attacks or they're overreach or for
whatever reason we don't support them
mean it seems to me it shouldn't matter
what context a student is being educated
in that they be safe they need to be
safe no matter
what I I don't think we can as
legislators or parents or anything else
guarantee safety um you
know go go to the playground go you know
play at the neighbor's house and you
know um we just uh have to hope that uh
and pray that they are always safe um
but um I just wanted to raise one other
question on the amendment um on line
11 it requires submission of the
who so non-public
schools um are going to be required to
do background checks and then submit
them to the Department of Education or
who so um as described under RSA 18913a
so so it may be addressed in that I'm
not an expert on this bill Glenn but it
may be addressed um in that um I I I I
was also wondering if if it might be a
benefit to to the committee to maybe get
a representative from the Department of
Safety in here because Glenn you just
you just said you know things like well
prenda is doing it and others are doing
it and it would really be good to
understand what it is here because the
state of New Hampshire requires um uh
employees that are that are that are uh
working with our public school students
to um to uh to have an FBI criminal
records check prior to to employment and
if that the standard we should
understand if if the the you know the
products that are listed here by prena
and possibly by others uh are are
equivalent to that are the same as that
or or somehow different uh than that so
that we can sort of compare apples
whether we're comparing talking about
Apples to Apples here and um and I think
Miss Venton has done a done a tremendous
job to try to provide some advice to to
this committee uh with respect to the
the um uh how the the I guess the um how
robust these these various
uh criminal records checks are but uh
you know when we when we go from the
statute and what we've heard in
testimony before and then we go to the
Pena letter we're seeing different terms
here we're seeing terms like Federal
Criminal search and a national criminal
search um
whether that's the same as an FBI
criminal history records check I don't
know and and U maybe there's somebody
from the Department of Safety that can
that can help advise this committee on
what the FBI does and what um what some
of the the third parties like Checker
and others that have um uh been
discussed what what products they
provide uh and and what level of safety
um uh or at least what level of um of of
assurance they're um they're providing
the entities that are requesting these
um history checks thank you
representative lad thank you very much
uh Mr chair um I I think we've got to be
very careful we're not going to compare
what we're doing right here in 628 to
what we were just looking at in
267 we're talking about separate areas
of statutory
language in the one we just dealt with
267 we're talking about
18913a
1A if you were to look at that statutory
language in
1B which we haven't even focused on it
specifically says a nonpublic school may
elect to require criminal records check
on selected employees so 1B talks to the
non-public this right we have right here
in 628 it's also talking about
nonpublic
so there's another area statute says
they may elect to do this now they were
saying right here in this which we're
not changing 1B at all that it's going
required only for non that's
right
nonpublic only the ones that participate
I I'd be very careful there because you
know when you start involving
nonpublic there's a reason why we had
the May there before regardless of where
you know the the students which are
being tuition to them whether it be
through a tuition program or through an
sort yes
represent I feel the need to make this
comment um
it seems to me that in this committee we
are often talking about issues where we
agree on the what I'm thinking mental
health I'm thinking school lunch feeding
children children not going
hungry here's another one safety of
children I care deeply about those poor
children who suffered during that crisis
okay I didn't mean to downplay it by not
mentioning you know
um what we seem to always disagree on is
the how and often that how regards
government overreach you may call it an
attack I'll be more subtle call it
government overreach is what this is
about and the difference between these
two bills is that the previous one was
about public schools okay I don't think
the government can overreach in their
own schools but this one's about private
schools so that's what I take issue
with okay so so just
um and and and I appreciate your your
your your your com comments Arlene and
and I apologize for my earlier um um
Interruption so
uh but but I what I what what you just
were were suggesting uh reminded me of a
of a bill that that was passed earlier
this year
um that would uh would allow a um Public
School Board to contract with a private
school for um to to provide educational
program for all of its students and in
that case
obligations I I and maybe this is
another attorney Fenton question what
are the obligations that the local
school board the contracting school
board has in terms of assuring the um
the the uh
or assuring I guess assuring the safety
of its of of their public school
students in an environment where um
where where the employees of that
private school have undergone uh FBI
criminal history checks the same way an
employee of a of a um a direct employee
of a public school uh so does that does
that apply to the Contra to a public
school district that contracts with a
private school for Educational Services
does that private school have to comply
with the same
FBI it's it's it's it's really related
to the one we're talking about right now
628 which which is specific to
non-public schools that are providing
Services Under learn everywhere and efas
but um but if um if the argument goes
that non-public schools should not be
mandated to provide to require criminal
history checks on employees does that
does that also apply to when a
non-public school is contracted by a
school district to provide all
Educational Services um for their for
their
students well we have a we have a bill
that um yeah I mean there's there's a
bill that says that um that a school
board can approve a non-public school
for um under tuition uh agreement for to
provide services for its students so
what does that non-public school have as
far as um as far as FBI criminal history
staff yeah yeah right and I thought a
couple of years ago Rick that there that
we were that e uh that Edna was doing a
were there was is there a study
committee hist whether it was sb8 at the
time or not but we we underneath the
tuition School tuition program where the
local school board makes the decision
where the kids are going to go to they
have to they they approve the local
board approves that receiving School
based
upon certain identified requirements
that are in that language I'd have to go
back and but I know the health and
safety are are all part of that um can't
education the the the local school
district is still responsible for
providing yeah oh yes that's sending
school still responsible for that but
the but the receiving school which may
be
a a school like fford Academy which is
in Vermont which is taking kids from all
over this side of the Connecticut River
um they may not provide all those Serv
services but they meet whatever the
local board has set up and I I think
they do meet those standards because
they're pretty well established school
um but um we'd have to look at the
statute see specifically what it say
right um I I think maybe that's headed
in a different direction than um our
Focus right now and we're um a little
bit behind uh a schedule um with our
next two bills so uh if there any final
comments let me just I think I want to
respond to the issue of
overreach I think one of the concerns
here is that as we begin to expand
public Monies to other
entities it is the responsibility of
this committee and of this
legislature to ensure that those public
monies have the have the appropriate
oversight and this happens to be I we
can all agree on the issue of student
safety but I think
it's not it's not like You' still have
got these private entities out there
that are operating independently once
they begin to receive public
monies taxpayer
monies then it is the legislator's
responsibility to make sure that the
appropriate oversight is there and I
think that is really the I can't speak
for representative Tanner but I think
that's the intent here is that when you
have public monies going into these
various programs
that there needs to be some oversight
some some entity that's looking out to
make sure that the uh taxpayers are in
fact getting that kind of oversight
that's needed that's that's that's I
think what the intent is here thank you
um so given the time and we have some
members of the uh uh next subcommittee
who have been sitting uh waiting for a
little while um once you come forward
and we um will take up our next two
bills um the first of which is House
Bill
623 establishing a teacher loan
forgiveness
623 right and um with 623 we had the uh
original Bill and then a uh an amendment
um put forward by representative Miler
uh
02218 I'm ready to speak to
great um you're up all
right oh okay just one minute
for
water
whatever
yeah you got a couple
here 218 21
over there in the Senate and
right of all those bills I like the one
in the Senate you signed on to that did
I 217 oh where where it came from it
came from ID oh oh thank
one I noticed that you are stand out all
alone yeah
uh yeah yeah but you know it
it's that comes from the from Idaho and
it
had a lot of I would say 90% of Idaho's
language and it's
solid
huh I didn't even realize that yeah I
either no I think I remember seeing that
and saying how did I get on now well
you're on it
yeah
yeah why
I'm I'm not really on the committee I'm
just sitting here you're there there
yeah that was basketb seon oh yeah
basketball season practice first
practice was what today's Tuesday
yesterday Junior he's a junior
yeah he came home to visit last last
week how much is it br oh he's he's now
at 7 foot actually a little over that
and and he came home and visit he lasted
one night it was so hectic to around the
house he said I can go back to college
so he's back there those little guys oh
yeah little 5-year-old
nuts and actually not nuts just you know
always wanting
attention course that's that's nature of
a
five-year-old
tomorrow
morning
is coffee machine working coffee
tomorrow
that
I I think maybe we're finally ready to
uh begin these this set of
bills um apologize for the delayed start
um me got into a a little bit of lengthy
conversation with the previous
ones um but this uh
first uh bill is uh 218
and representative Miler I think you
just handed out an amendment no mine
mine is were two 61 oh 623 right yeah
I'm sorry that's what we're doing 623
all right all right so here's where we
are with this uh
baby uh when we when we left the last
session I did take this bill uh to our
teacher shortage committee and did pass
it out seeking some of their
input uh frankly I didn't get much uh
but I did uh did get an opportunity to
work with uh Steve applebe on this when
we left uh this conversation last time
there were five areas of
concern one area was that the uh that
this should be a state program
administered by the doe and not uh uh
obligating local school districts to
have to budget uh for this that was one
area uh second was an area of whether or
not this could be retroactive to other
uh to employees that would qualify under
that one to five year
stipulation uh the third area that we
talked about was should we include in
the bill also shortage of teachers in
special education math and
science uh the fourth area that we
talked about was that it should be more
than just University graduates from the
University
system um and uh the fifth area was kind
of the definition of the teacher
shortage so what we've done in this
amendment is that we won we have uh made
this a state
program on the sixth area was of course
the cost cost of the program uh so what
we've done in this amendment we've made
this uh a basically Department program
to be administered by the
department uh in thinking about the
issue of having it retro OS said that
that's a very difficult kind of language
to put in to make it retro rather that
it should be more prospective rather
than
retrospective um then we looked at the
issue of whether or not should
include uh shortages in special ed
teachers and administrators Math and
Science and I talked with applebe about
this at length and we both came to the
conclusion no that this should be a
program that basically deals with as
it's as it's as it's intended is to deal
with the rural and um and the
those Pro those school districts that
are um are underperforming schools so we
did not include that in here uh we also
then excluded the issue of only
university only University students and
that it would be any new teacher that
would be uh going into a school district
uh then the other area deals with the um
the financing of this and I learned uh
recently that the current um fund
balance of the education and trust fund
is $220 million that's sitting there so
the 1 million and the2 million
respectively that are mentioned in the
um bill should be able to have ample
funding from the trust fund uh and then
we also updated the um dates that this
would be uh appropriate you also will
note on uh the third page line
three uh there's an indicator that
including the cost of administering by
the department and talking with Mr
applebe he he didn't think it was going
to take a lot to do this but he said
he'd like to have at least some note
that if he had to have an employee that
would work you know 20% of the time or
something that would be covered uh by
the uh by the appropriation so those
were the changes that we made and uh
that's uh where this where we stand with
this right now Mr chair
thank you um comments or questions for
cascaden uh thank you
um I'm trying to figure out what would
identify a rural school and I think it's
20 enoll students per square mile so can
the department kind of come up with a
list of schools based on that criteria
was their criteria okay so they've got
definitions I didn't put obviously in
the bill but they have def definitions
for um uh both Rural and those
underperforming
schools just yeah just one more question
um UNH had done a a rurual um school
program I don't know if that's still
operating or was it just a 5year grant
project you I don't know the status of
that no but I am aware of that program
yes because it was very successful if
the state could do something very
similar um which it sounds like this
would do that does some of that yeah
coupled with a mentor program obviously
okay further questions for
representative Miler or um comments uh
generally on the uh the proposed
amendment I do have one question um
the uh appropriation of $1 million for
25 and 2 million for
26 um those are uh caps to the program
um so that if there are you know more
new teachers let's say um I do believe
somewhere in here that the governor is
authorized to draw more okay yes I see
it um on page three and yeah I'll C the
million and two million is a shot that
right have no idea what that would be
y I do know that that as represent lad
said
earlier representative lad said earlier
there is a a p a very similar Bill
pending in the senate in
217 um so I just I want to make sure
that we have uh both bills may come into
if if this were to pass would come into
some kind of a conference committee
to look at whatever the differences are
of the bills and um 217 is um a retained
bill in the Senate as well correct yes
yeah
yeah repr K Ken so this loan repayment
would apply to a firste teacher going
into a rural District yes okay is there
any commitment for them to stay so many
years within that District or does it
matter we we talked about that we talked
about you know if you go from one one
school in the district to another school
in the same district we just we just
want to get this moving to try to have
some incentive for people to to be in
these Rural and under under service
schools
yeah um yeah uh thank you I had a a good
telephone conversation with Brian
sitting here with us today just last
night or it was yesterday afternoon
somewhere along the way Brian um that
this uh we have a number of bills right
here coming for us we have 6 23 218 and
217 which is in the
Senate 217 then um in our my discussion
with uh Mr Hawkins was that it kind of
Echoes legislation that was recently
passed by the state of Idaho uh and
there is a very similar bill which they
passed they used uh much of the same
language which you're seeing here
including the amount of money to be
awarded over the first second third
fourth
years um they also addressed rule
isolation schools uh pursuant to what
they identify as rule out in Idaho of
course their definition going to be a
little bit different than what we have
here because they really do have some
rule rural areas out there uh but they
also have monies going towards economic
disadvantage school-based on
eligibilities that receive uh Title One
monies so that would bring in in our
case
Manchester and those schools which are
economically um hurting so it's it's not
it's just not just rule it's rule in
underserved uh Educators and and
districts which are are hampered by the
the the economic situation within those
communities and federal dollars which
they receive so I would really uh
because the whole concept what I see
what Idaho did is very positive and
that's reflected in 217 and to a degree
in 218 as well it's
all this language is kind of coming
together so um i' i' I'd encourage us to
you know I had a good conversation with
Brian on that he also forwarded to me
the information that came from Idaho
with their
legislation and uh how how it's working
um seems to be a real good program so I
think maybe there's room here for
merging these things into something that
we have and we discuss this again
tomorrow at 1:00 with the teacher
shortage committee and we're just
finishing that up but uh I know that
this will be a point of discussion there
as
well representative cascaden thank you I
I don't know if this addresses it on
line four it does have Part B this on
page two economic disadvantage of the
school based on eligibility for funds
pursuant to Title One Part A of the
elementary and and secondary Education
Act I don't know if that's what you were
talking about but that would be included
here from what I I
understand represent Damon thank you on
the same topic um charlot actually spoke
to what I was thinking about that
Manchester
Claremont um probably some other
communities wouldn't qualify as rural
based on the definition in first page
line
2324 so I keep wondering if this
shouldn't be rural or underperforming
school education program or and or so in
other words you'd be eligible if you
taught in either the rural District the
underperforming or
both you know um I look at Claremont and
Newport as desperately needing this to
help with retention but I don't think
they qualify as rural repres I agree
with the the rural part of that and the
or and but I when we say or underperform
pering School
District um I like the language that
Idol has even more and it reads
specifically economic disadvantage of
the school based on eligibility for
funds pursuant to Title One Part a
federal Elementary and secretary
Education Act as
amended um so it's the economic money
flowing to it and that's that economic
base it's not necessarily
underperforming which might you know
well you're not performing well with the
achievement scores and I don't think we
should be basing on that I think it's
should be based on this other Target
which uh Idaho put in place I I think
maybe that language from Idaho is what
you were referring to representative
Damon in terms of economic disadvantage
on Roman
2B um so I think if anything um Roman 6
where it says role and
underperforming School educator it
really should refer to Roman 2 which has
two
yes
sure okay may I yes go ahead I if I may
my my concern is is um I don't know
what's going to happen to 2117 in the
Senate all right and so I think by
having two concurrent Two Bills moving
in a concurrent
fashion um I have let me I have Greater
Hope for the house because I don't know
what's going to happen in the Senate
so it's always a crap shoot over in the
S it is and I so my sense is if if if
something were to possibly happen in the
Senate obviously it's going to come over
to here again it's we're going to see it
here but I just think
um we've not been able to get much uh as
a result of the uh teacher shortage
committee through uh before the the
house uh and so that was why I was even
though I knew that 217 was moving
through it I just thought we should have
another one over here too as a
compliment right they complement one
another yeah and I just off from if
there any Senators um tuning in on my
apologies for that prior comment about a
crapshoot um represent cordelli yes um I
would I would suggest that
we have a side by side made here between
217 and 263 of course we have two
um is is is uh doesn't really specify
all the things that 218
does um or 217 because 217 and 218 are
are verbage is very very
263 are are these three bills all for
the the same intent the same purpose
yeah because when when I look at 217 and
218 and
Idaho the numbers are the same Romans 7
is on on on
2623 those are the same numbers that
appear in the others uh one500 2500 3
3500 4500 the $1 million $2 million same
thing uh as we see in all these bills so
I I think there's there's a possibility
here we could be able to use one of
these bills as coming from the house and
parallel it with
27 and I think we have a better chance
of getting something happened
I I I would suggest that we have general
for four work on a side by side for us y
we can make that request could I ask one
question um resident Miler on your
amendment to make sure I have my
understanding correct in terms of the um
the award so that if a teacher an
educator goes into one of the um uh um
schools that we're defining here um they
could and they stay for four years years
um they could get uh a total of uh I
think $112,000 that's correct
okay and if if they leave beforehand
they would just get whatever they've
been uh based on the number of years
correct okay thank you I mean I I think
I think frankly the intent here
is it's kind of a
um a um an incentive that hopefully if
they're there for three or four years
they'll want to stay I mean that's
really that's what the intent is here as
well as to help them out too sure
represent
Damon thank you I just wanted to add a
perspective um last night I was at a
Goan school board meeting Goan tuitions
all their students to other schools um
kada2 and the main meeting was Newport
School District which uh receives their
students they had nine people presenting
the various different programs in the
Newport school district and in the
discussion it came out that the entry
level salary in Newport for a bachelor's
level teacher is
$37,000 in
change you know it just I mean we know
how different the payment the salaries
are in different
districts but you can go 15 minutes down
the road to sunap and get5 to $220,000
more so the need for this to
address these economically poor
districts is
profound I I would just come in I think
that we see that in many professions um
you know nursing uh I know for instance
with County nursing homes versus
hospitals Etc so um representative L
yeah in uh my conversation the other
evening too um there there are some
different is you know two of the bills
have four years one has five years but I
I'm looking right at the titles right
now and I I think that we got to be very
careful uh of the the impact we may get
from some people within our community
when we talk about forgiveness you might
have those saying well I just went to
school and got a two-year skill uh
training in an associates degree I'm not
going to get any forgiveness on that
skill I paid my way whereas I look at
the other two bills one says as a title
uh establishing an early educated
professional development Grant taking
that word forgiveness out the other one
217 establishing a rule in underserved
Area Educator incentive program for
higher education and making
appropriation thereof therefore I think
it's it's I I I just inclined to think
that when we talking about forgiveness
what's are we going to be doing next for
what other training and skills areas uh
whereas we're recognizing there is a
shortage and C certain areas we have
problems in underserved area economic
service areas like Manchester with that
shortage of Science and Math and special
education Etc um I I think that the
whole thing is not necessarily the
primary purpose for this is to get
qualified people into the classroom to
teach and to keep people there rather
than than jumping ship and going and
working for Exxon Mobile or some other
outfit uh and but so I'd rather not call
this a pro forgiveness program I'd
rather
address something more specific like 218
or
217 right I I believe representative
miler in your Amendment you did change
the
title well it says incentive program you
I was looking at the original yeah the
original title which know it it says
early educated professional development
on summer on 218 uh 623
says in it does say loan forgiveness
program it said loan forgiveness
program on on the initial right right
that's got to change right in 322
Amendment
2322 it looks like uh the title is
replaced with establishing the rural and
underperforming school educator
incentive program and making an
appropriation therefore that's echoing
217 which I think is
appropriate yeah yeah
okay yes representative mcon thank you
um I posed a similar question at our
last meeting on this bill but it still
pertains to the amendment specifically
page three beginning on line five which
is again the governor being authorized
to draw a warrant for the additional sum
out of any money in the treasur
is that a typical practice to not have
checked by the executive counsil
especially as wring to not have a limit
on that says any money could that just
be unlimited and is that a mistake or
should that be addressed within this
bill to put a cap there perhaps process
right the process for that is that any
money it's it's going to have to go
through
fiscal so there is a legislative step uh
which oversees this process so that's a
committee a joint committee of the
Senate and the house and then it's
everything that goes before the governor
and counsil goes through fiscal so I I
think and this is typically the way
things are written when we're at the
second year or a year in which we have
already approved the budget so we're
looking where can we go to find these
monies uh whether through a Federal
grant a state money might have something
doe or are we going to go back and dip
into the a trust fund of kind and I
believe that um is in the education
trust fund similar language so that if
there is not a surplus and there is
money needed the governor can just uh
draw a warrant for the needed funds
yeah good question yeah further
questions on this bill or you know we'll
we'll see about a a side by side and um
well I I'll work uh I'm trying to maybe
have another amendment that that makes
it even closer okay great thank you when
you talk about side by side you mean
218 yeah I I really think that's where
we need to go to to Really spread it out
yeah I think we need to incorporate this
compared to what the Senate has if we
can get on the same page pretty much or
we can get them on our page I think we
have a better chance having this move
forward and we do know that uh the those
two bills have been mimicked off of
other states specifically
idah and and that's that's important to
help carry something through where
they're seeing success in the program
out
there and I can speak to where I was on
the northwest when I was a Ministry up
in the Northwest we had a similar
program it works it works helps keep
people so um I think it's a good effort
um the side by side 218 217 I do that
side by side and try to match those and
I put the time and effort there Mel
rather than putting it in a 623 you're a
anyways but put 623 on it oh yeah put
623 there too but it's going to have to
come together yeah yeah great yes a
question for representative Myer about
the amendment were the grant or partial
years factored in if a teacher stay only
part of a year and then had to leave
would they get half of the amount for a
giving year or is that just not factored
in good question I don't have an answer
to that
question my my my presumption is is that
the the grant would not be awarded until
at the end of the end of the to have
completed the cont complete
contract so they're always in a year in
re okay thank you
um any further comments on 623 um and I
think we've at the same time talked
about uh
218 uh pretty much in terms of where we
wanted to go to uh um look at a
comparison between the three bills um uh
heading into I I don't think we need a a
further meeting until November um I
think we can uh deal deal with it at
that point if that's okay yeah can I say
one more thing sure 623 is very specific
to it talks about the university system
no not anymore okay so we're we're
taking that all aside good it's all gone
that's great straight break
yeah so starting to shape up like the
other two bills yeah yeah yeah yeah good
any further um comments on either of
these two bills or we uh good for the
day and uh thank you for the uh uh new
members joining us uh recently uh sorry
you had to wait so
long but um thank you everybody and I
day so what she should do is make a a
six
that